hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan side
tonight we're gonna watch the trailer
for Mortal Kombat X que no gameplay
fatalities trailer mm-hmm for Mortal
Kombat 10 yeah that's what it's for us
when Mortal Kombat X stands for Donal I
said it I'm just so excited you know
nerville I'm nervous yeah like everyone
says how good it is what if I don't like
it I'm kind of nervous if you don't like
it you got a damn mouth and you go in
the corner and not say anything yeah
yeah yeah I should just lie but you're
probably gonna like the other ones yeah
yeah it's gonna be okay okay it's okay
buddy okay as people are so mean don't
feed the trolls okay see if they might
pick up a bit
18
[Music]
oh Jesus dude did you hear that
that was a woman like watching the how
did you beat this guy I have no idea oh
it's looking awesome
Oh this dude's my jam
damn man this guy is so [ __ ]
Ella bad about world combat she's all
fatalities no yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Danny's scary isn't it he's like scary
Blazers I think about is like playing
against him I'm not even like concerned
with it I'm just gonna play T that's
that's pretty scary holy [ __ ] I mean
just recently the place how cool this
game's gonna be I can't stress enough
how bad I am at finding games and how
much I like just avoid them like the
plague but God if you it does take
patience special in like Mortal Kombat
cuz yeah it's a lot of [ __ ] things
yeah I'm not that good with combos with
like the sticks and stuff but it like
Smash Bros Smash Bros a get anyone can
do Smash Bros man come on you're better
than that
I'm sold your insults and ash Bros is
amazing it's fashion I know but like
those controls that have combat games
those are easy to pick up on yeah it's
the same controls for every character
yeah still kick your ways yes we should
have you last time we'll do a match an
n64 a match in melee and a matching bra
oh did and then then you won for the Wii
[Music]
but yeah Mortal Kombat I mean [ __ ] I'm
excited I'm excited I'm really excited
about
I want to own it cuz I'm gonna be that
cool guy at the party who has Mortal
Kombat and then we're all gonna be
playing it game drunk
that's me be cool you want to be cool
kid yeah that would life your life goals
and expectancies yeah well I think I
have a youtube channel I bring hot
[ __ ] on the channel rock is on [ __ ]
I want people to start thinking if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe right here oh and dad has his
own channel subscribers gaming channel
it's fun stuff on there and Dan Yeol
we're gonna do some shoutouts you okay
Kevin Beckford I actually reply back to
this comment hi ryan wrong
you never shouting me out that's why I
sing this song just read it out cuz it
won't be long I know it must be scary
always have to look at a guy named Jerry
is he is not ugly he's handsome but you
know that he's faces Harry you show me
your real he spent REE L but it got
rejected
give me a shadow I'll show you all your
videos that you've collected so what
he's saying is rap as I feel like he was
going more for rhymes than actually
making sense and your rapping skills
need to improve my friend
I just appreciate your effort you know
what the problem is man it's just no
one's ever ready to be a rap song before
someone just did I know and he wrote it
for me and yeah I have the hardest time
accepting it I just don't know how to
accept something good so lonely I pretty
hot [ __ ] on the channel but try to
make myself look like the cool kid I
don't know how to accept kind words like
this this is the sweetest thing any guys
ever done for me yeah
yeah Robert Carter said this hey Ryan
huge fan you're so awesome and I was
wearing of you can give me a shout-out
yes Robert Carr he's got a picture of
Deadpool man nice but do you think you
are huh raagh that thumbnail come on man
come on you Deadpool is he's the [ __ ]
you think you can represent him well
[ __ ] do you think you are huh yeah dumb
son of a [ __ ] joke Robert didn't get it
wrong back to Robert Carr yeah ah yo ah
Robert De Niro Meet the Fockers yeah
basically modern day version
I think Robert can rock the Deadpool I
think Robert arrived the Deadpool - I
just I only know De Niro I don't know
what happy DeNiro impression is that's
true but yeah Robert you have a good
night my friend you honor that name is
short for a dick no no isn't isn't
Robert - you got a wrong as in Robert
the word for that's actually take a
short no Richard you're thinking of
Richard you're so stupid ed Dark Lord
double X 69 haha you know some what I
like great reaction man may have a shout
out sometime unless I already did
Dark Lord at double X 69 don't recall if
I gave you a shatter or not but I do
recall seeing your comments a lot so you
know what man you you deserve a
shout-out and plus it's just hard for me
to keep track sometimes so yeah yeah
Dark Horse double axe 69 69 best
position in the world wait it's coming
back to me I think I have given a
shout-out I remember making this joke
before and I never make the same joke
twice my god
you son of a [ __ ] I'll get my god
tonight will you ride your ass
lasers